whether you specialize in networking or
security learn how to implement load
balancing and content delivery optimize
your network for performance and cost
and understand key risk mitigation and
response tactics with the networking and
security learning path this path was
designed to guide you no matter where
you are in your Learning Journey start
at the first stop if you're new to
Google cloud or jump in at a different
stop if you're enhancing an existing
skill set along the way earn skill
Badges and prepare to become Google
Cloud certified
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of core infrastructure
networking and security on Google Cloud
Google Cloud offers tracks for network
and security Engineers choose the track
fit for you and your interests
learn from Google Cloud experts via
instructor-led training or take
advantage of the flexibility of
on-demand the choice is completely up to
you Google Cloud offers multiple
modalities so you can learn how you want
to whether on demand or instructor-led
you will gain access to the same course
content and Labs so you won't miss out
on a hands-on experience
practice what you've learned polish your
skills and earn skill badges
show the world that you and your team
can create build and secure networks and
workloads in Google Cloud use skill
badges to gain recognition or to help
you land a new role
next up it's time to prepare to become
Google Cloud certified by taking the
instructor-led or on-demand course and
checking out the various guides and
Sample exam questions once you pass the
exam you're officially a certified
professional Cloud Network or security
engineer on Google Cloud
looking to continue learning or for a
different topic area Google Cloud offers
learning paths spanning across the
solution pillars from beginner to
Advanced this comprehensive learning
path will guide you along your Google
Cloud networking and security Learning
Journey time to get started